whether you like it or not magic is an
eSport this past weekend we saw the
first mythic Invitational for MTG Arena
at PAX with a million dollars in prize
money given out some incredible matches
incredible personalities and perhaps
most importantly 126 thousand peek
viewers on stream that is nearly triple
the amount of peak viewers magic had
before this weekend we can learn three
important things from that number one is
that MTG arena has completely changed
the game for magic two there were people
watching this weekend who have never
played or watched competitive magic in
their life and three magic is 100
percent and I know what you're thinking
why wasn't in any sport before well
there's a couple reasons for that
for one there was never an accessible
video game version of magic that's sort
of the E in eSports and I can already
hear the commenters starting to type
furiously about how MTG online existed
but MTG Online was inaccessible it was
basically a bunch of spreadsheets and if
you didn't understand paper magic you
weren't gonna understand MTG online on
top of that magic online cost
significant money to get into not as
much as paper magic but still quite a
bit an arena being free-to-play matters
a lot it's what gets people into the
game the way that after you watch league
you can just download League of Legends
for free and start playing this past
weekend was the first showing for MTG
arena as a new eSport and by all
accounts it was a success the event
itself was pretty fantastic there were
some problems with the format which I
will get to later don't worry but
overall it was great there were
fantastic matches and colorful
personalities which is exactly what you
want from your first eSports event just
think about canister and his ridiculous
hat or Asian Avenger talking about the
plains I also always wanted to say this
this is a postgame conference thing you
know we went out you know we played hard
they made plays and we made more plays I
just watch a lot of sports oh I wanted
to say that you made the best place the
stage itself also looked incredible you
had day 9 hosting and day 9 is actually
a pretty big yet I know he plays
automagically MTG Arena but
he went from hosting Ti to hosting of
this so feels like a big deal but you
had him coming up on stage and every
time he brings in a player sparks come
out of the ground then there's fire
everywhere it it looked like a huge
eSport style production something magic
has never had in the past magic has
always just been dudes at tables playing
paper cards which hasn't really hard to
follow and pay attention to and really
get excited about for somebody who
doesn't really know magic and now with
MTG arena you have this client where new
players can actually look at a game and
understand what's happening and trust me
when I say that it's better for new
players I mean it because I am a new
player I picked up magic for the first
time in January with MTG arena and I'm
basically obsessed with it now
I watched the mythic Invitational over
the weekend and I have never watched
competitive magic in my life every time
I've tried to it really did just look
boring and I know that's probably
complete heresy to people who've been
playing magic for years but at the same
time you do have to want your game to
grow and this weekend is a perfect sign
of how MTG can grow into a huge
successful eSport now when it comes to
growth you do have to answer some of the
problems such a tournament had and there
was one big one the format C duo
standard is not great it's basically
glorified best of ones which if you
don't understand why that could be bad
you have to look no further than what
happened to pro player Jerry Thompson
who got absolutely [ __ ] by the format
his way to try to win this game all
right
the game has gone to time and Wyatt
Darby walks off with a victory oh wow
Wow okay and that is a result of that
first game
hey for so long what makes duo state are
different from regular magic is that in
a regular magic you bring one deck and a
sideboard of 15 cards to swap into your
deck between games to adapt to your
opponent's deck into a standard and said
you get to bring two decks and they can
be completely different the same the
same deck with very slight differences
but you only get these two decks and you
can't swap in stuff to deal with your
opponent strategies the other thing it
adds is a hard time limit on the length
of matches now paper magic also has a
time limit but it almost never comes up
because it's an hour long and you get a
reasonable warning before you hit it in
this case there wasn't really much of a
warning
and while MTG arena does have
self-imposed time limits those are for
individual turns not for entire series
so look yes the format is a problem most
pro players would prefer bo threes
however we can fix that and more
importantly that format is kind of the
thing that MTG arena is bringing to the
table most new players are playing via
ones and remember when I said I was a
new player I played Bo ones that first
month I played MTG arena I didn't have
the cards to make a sideboard I didn't
really understand how side boarding work
I didn't get into until you know a month
or two afterwards and look if none of
that made any sense to you that is okay
the only thing you have to understand is
that the format sucked and it can be
fixed what doesn't need to be changed
though is the game itself magic has been
around for 26 years and it's finally
getting its shot at being a huge eSport
in the way that it never dreamed of
before you have to be paying attention
to magic as an eSport going forward well
I understand you probably weren't paying
attention before this weekend I wasn't
paying attention before like four months
ago but they got my cynical ass they can
probably get yours too magic has the
potential to be the next big eSport
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button